bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro de municipales 2014 sûreté
défilent chaque semaine l'intégralité de
la campagne à saint quentin en yvelines
et dans les principales villes du
département une actualité à retrouver
également sur un site internet lancé par
la rédaction pour ces élections et dont
l'adresse s'affiche actuellement
reportages interviews débats ainsi
qu'une rubrique carnet de campagne pour
suivre les dates de meetings des
candidats pour débuter cette édition du
18 février le point sur la campagne
d'europe écologie les verts à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pas de tête de
liste mais des alliances avec les
candidats déclarés
toutes les explications à suivre europe
ecologie les verts sur saint quentin a
choisi de de participer à l'union de la
gauche
donc c'est à dire participer à toutes
les listes de rassemblement avec le
parti socialiste avec le parti
communiste front de gauche donc sur les
communes de la communauté
d'agglomération une union de la gauche
dès le premier tour pour faire barrage à
la droite et on échange la garantie de
siéger à la communauté d'agglomération
quatre à cinq élus dans le meilleur des
cas
il est aucun écologiste lors de la
précédente mandature et cela pourrait
permettre de mieux se faire entendre
lors des prises de décision il ya des
sujets sur lesquels on va être proche il
ya des sujets sur lesquels on sera en
désaccord le tout c'est de bien les
identifier dès le début et qui ait pas
d'ambiguïté je pense que les électeurs
ou comprendront que les listes de gauche
font des listes au rassemblement et que
qui dit rassemblement diversité nous on
est pour la diversité en politique comme
pour la biodiversité
si les points d'achoppement existe
europe écologie était farouchement
opposé à la réalisation du vélodrome et
s'opposera à l'installation d'une
station de ski sur la colline
d'elancourt les responsables locaux
affirment avoir obtenu des engagements
de la part des candidats pour ces
élections
autre formation politique qui s'explique
sur sa stratégie dans l'agglomération le
parti de gauche ces élections ont un
caractère national précisent les
dirigeants locaux c'est pourquoi
regarder les programmes présentés il
appelle à voter pour lui qu miserait et
le front de gauche à trappes à linge a
agi le front de gauche à la verrière et
enfin pour bertrand au lion et le ps à
magny les hameaux
dans les autres communes le parti de
gauche appellent à des listes autonomes
mais aussi conquérante
puisque nous sommes dans l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines reste onze
y encore quelques instants avec ses
images de la dernière séance du conseil
communautaire présidé par robert
cadalbert il a en effet choisi de ne pas
se représenter en mars prochain sur une
liste un retrait de la vie politique
locale à 69 ans après et 16 ans à ce
poste de président du sam d'abord et
puis ensuite de la casse qui le
principal intéressé ne cachait pas son
émotion jeudi dernier lui qui a présidé
une centaine de séances et apposer sa
signature à plus de 500 milles reprises
et vous le savez pour la première fois
cette année nous voterons les électeurs
voteront également pour leurs élus au
sein de cette agglomération en plus de
désigner leurs maires et nous avons donc
demandé à robert cadalbert ce qu'ils
pensaient de ces changements mais aussi
des conséquences à attendre toujours dit
c'est bien que les conseillers
communautaires soient lus sur les
directement par la population suffrage
universel direct
sauf que le législateur a pas osé aller
jusqu'au bout et se fait que on va voir
un exécutif qui sera pas forcément très
clair sortie des urnes et vous aurez des
maires qui ont largement gagné qui
seront là et leurs opposants risquent
d'avoir des responsabilités importantes
à l'inter comité donc vous voyez dans
l'assemblée des débats où je perds par
des règlements de comptes l'on va des
débats entre opposition et majorité
d'une commune qui s'exposeront au sein
de l'agglomération
ce qui n'était pas le cas dans dans ce
système la marine le pen en soutien aux
têtes de liste front national dans le
département un déplacement remarqué la
semaine dernière au chesnay en 2008
aucune liste frontiste n'avait été
déposée aujourd'hui le chiffre de 23
candidats est avancé 23 listes pour 600
colistiers du rassemblement bleu marine
aussi bien montini plaisir les clercs ou
encore elancourt elle la formation
espère obtenir dans les yvelines une
trentaine d'élus et grâce notamment à de
probables triangulaire il ya eu un
effort absolument spectaculaire puisque
avait 0 lille en 2008 par conséquent
arriver à avoir 23 tête de liste avec
déjà un grand nombre de ces dix qui sont
d'ores et déjà bouclé c'est un très bel
effort d'implantation locale c'est une
priorité pour le front national ne
maintiendront bien sûr au second tour
car
voulons absolument porter la voix du bon
sens dans les conseils municipaux et
nous apparaît que en matière de bon sens
l'ump le ps
ont quand même énormément de retard et
le front national qui vient d'annoncer
le dépôt officiel en préfecture de sa
première liste cette semaine celle de
philippe chevrier à rambouillet philippe
chevrier par ailleurs responsable
départemental de cette formation
une information qui concerne versailles
à présent et cette liste divers droite
menée par benoît de saint sernin sa
liste change de nom ne dit plus
versailles nous rassemble mais
versailles 90000 voisins autre
changement qui explique ce changement de
nom le départ des sept membres du
collectif citoyen versailles nous
rassemble municipales 2014 l'émission
qui se poursuit comme chaque mardi à
18h30 sur tv fils vous le savez aussi
des débats à suivre ce sera bien
évidemment chaque mardi et chaque jeudi
à 20 heures jusqu'à la veille du premier
tour pour l'instant nous partons à
coignières à la rencontre des candidats
qui s'affrontent sur cette ville de
liste qui s'affrontent l'une des divers
droite soutenu par l'ump et puis l'autre
ps de didier fischer
le maire sortant fall qui est en place
depuis bientôt 30 ans à face au
conseiller régional elle d'ile-de-france
des portraits signés olivier maniscalco
à coignières deux candidats pour ces
municipales 2014 tout d'abord le maire
sortant ump henri pailleux à la tête de
la ville depuis 1986 en politique dès
1958 il se qualifie de gaulliste ou de
fillonniste aujourd'hui réélu dès le
premier tour en 2008 cet ancien
enseignant docteur en physique se
présente pour un sixième mandat
consécutif sans pour autant penser se
présenter pour le mandat de trop je dois
dire que je me suis réellement posé la
question de savoir si c'était pas comme
certains le disent un mandat de trop et
bras comme je la chantais pour l'assurer
eh bien je suis intimement convaincu
intimement persuadé que j'ai encore de
grands services à rendre à lui de
coignières et aux colères à coignières
son bilan parle pour lui en trente ans
henri payet a fait de sa vie un bassin
économique attractif avec près de 800
entreprises pour 6000 emplois en termes
d'investissements pour les équipements
de la ville son dernier mandat fut un
monde un record
mais paradoxe étonnant ans
2013 il baisse les impôts locaux de 10%
grâce à une dette faible et des fonds
disponibles important face à henri
paillet dans cette élection didier
fischer socialiste qui conduira la liste
poignard pour tous installés dans la
ville depuis sept ans cet enseignant
docteur en histoire est également
conseiller régional d'île de france
depuis 2004
en 2008 il est deuxième de liste de
marie claude renaud candidate battue par
henri pailleux il devient membre de
l'opposition au conseil municipal de
coignières une opposition qui selon lui
a fait avancer les choses dans la ville
c'est vrai qu'on peut apparaître assez
facilement comme des gens qui critiquent
sans faire de véritables propositions
alors ça pète et le cas quand même de
notre équipe on était une équipe
sérieuse qui a travaillé justement en
proposant et c'est peut-être ça qui est
un petit peu ennuyé la municipalité mais
qui a fait aussi que durant cette
mandature monsieur pas eu à faire sur en
plus de choses qui ne rêve qu'il
n'aurait fait sans nous on a été
l'aiguillon démocratique en fait dans la
commune
pour didier fischer tous les problèmes
n'ont pas été réglés il faut aller plus
loin sur certains thèmes l'emploi déjà
ou coignières connaît un taux de chômage
plus élevé que celui du département
malgré son bassin économique important
les transports en commun qu'ils jugent
insuffisant pour les coigné rien
excentré par endroits où pour se rendre
à la gare sncf
enfin le problème de la nationale 10 qui
fracturent la ville en deux et qui reste
un danger pour les enfants qui la
traversent chaque matin afin de se
rendre à l'école ces deux hommes qui se
connaissent bien en découdront le 23
mars en 2008 henri paillet l'avait
emporté avec plus de 61% des voix autres
portraits de candidats que je vous
propose de découvrir à présent ceux de
bertrand au lion et d'aurore berger il
se présente donc du ps et de l'ump dans
la commune de magny les hameaux une
commune
résultat est loin d'être acquis un camp
ou un autre ce sont finalement deux
listes qui s'affrontent à magny les
hameaux pour ces municipales tenté par
l'aventuré le front de gauche a
finalement décidé de rejoindre dès le
premier tour bertron ou lyon le maire
socialiste sortant
pour l'opposition il s'agit d'un
rangement d'arrière cuisine il faut dire
que la tête de liste ump udf n'a pas
pour habitude de mâcher ses mots
aurore bergé et n'a pas encore 30 ans
mais ses prises de positions déconcerte
au sein même parfois de sa propre
famille politique à l'image de son
engagement l'an dernier en faveur du
mariage homosexuel
je ne comprends pas l'argument qui est
de dire que le mot mariage gêne je ne
comprends pas l'argument qui est de dire
que et puis de toute façon on ne retire
rien à ceux qui veulent continuer à se
marier religieusement engagé en
politique à 16 ans à l'ump au lendemain
de l'accession second tour de la
présidentielle du front national l'a
ensuite fait ses armes avec la députée
et ancienne ministre valérie pécresse
très active sur les réseaux sociaux très
présente dans les médias nationaux voire
même trop selon ses adversaires face à
aurore bergé bertrand ou lyon 37 ans
préfère rappeler son attachement à une
commune qui l'a vu grandir
j'ai démarré au conseil municipal des
jeunes
donc quand j'étais en quatrième on avait
fait une liste avec des amis au collège
j'ai voulu continuer à m'impliquer j'ai
été élu donc au conseil municipal en
1995 j'avais 18 ans c'est en 2012 à la
faveur du départ de jacquelot lloze
qu'il enfile les sharp de premier
magistrat de la ville l'accueil aux a
fait énormément pour la commune c'est un
maire très apprécié on a fait un passage
de relais tout en douceur dans la
continuité
quand j'ai besoin d'information par
rapport à l'historique de certains
dossiers je sais compter sur lui la
continuité maître mot du programme de
l'équipe sortante continuité en matière
de services et de lien social
même si l'on trouve aussi la volonté de
répondre aux demandes de logement ou
encore de sécurité
aurore bergé elle développe une dizaine
de points du développement économique à
la création d'un forum de la réussite
pour l'insertion professionnelle elle
veut surtout changer la méthode
notamment pour la réforme des rythmes
scolaires
ce que je note c'est que la concertation
n'a pas eu lieu puisque c'est certaines
personnes sont été choisi par la mairie
pour participer à des réunions et car
aucun moment il n'y a eu deux plénières
réunissant l'ensemble des manifs coin
afin de leur les consulter et de leur
présenter les premières pistes de
réflexion encore une fois cette
différence de méthode puisque nous on a
envie de faire une véritable
concertation si aurore bergé l'emporté
elle deviendrait l'une des plus jeune
élu local de france battant au passage
de deux ans le record de nicolas sarkozy
maire à 28 ans quant à bertrand au lion
- cas de victoire il pourra recevoir les
remerciements du reste des élus de
gauche de l'agglomération pour avoir
conservé une commune dont la droite a
fait sa priorité pour renverser le
conseil communautaire mardi jeudi à 20h
tv fil 78 vous propose des débats sur
les principales communes du département
et des yvelines jeudi dernier déjà
catherine mulato recevait les têtes de
listes à voisins le bretonneux quatre
listes dans cette commune celle du maire
ump udf alexis millette mais aussi celle
de son ancienne première adjointe
alexandra rosetti celle divers droite
également de jean-louis tison et enfin
la gauche représentée par jean h
soutenue par le parti socialiste
morceaux choisis de cette confrontation
si vous n'étiez pas avec nous et puis
sachez plus précisément que les
candidats vont s'exprimer à présent sur
la
le quartier de la remise est elle le
réaménagement qui fait débat vous allez
le voir chez moi l'aménagement de la
remise c'est le grand projet qui aurait
dû avoir lieu dans la voiture que je
vous rappelle que c'était notre sujet de
prédilection aux dernières élections à
tous et issa ya passé bon effectivement
le laminage voile remis doit intégrer
des logements accessibles à tous les
jeunes les jeunes familles les personnes
en difficultés et erreurs des actions
sociales oui mais pas que des gens c'est
en intégrant le logement social mais
vraiment des logements accessibles
vous savez que le logement et 35 à 40%
plus cher à bouazza que dans les autres
communes de la ville nouvelle
je suis quand même un problème voilà l
art du rhdp c'est justement leur veto
donc le double toxocarose 1 je vais des
logements je veux des lèvres moyen terme
heureux de savoir je vais faire baisser
je leur valeur de leur bien d'un quart
vous pouvez toujours très bon je veux
des logements d'accord je vais aussi des
activités des commerces et des espaces
publics limités des espaces verts
le périmètre n'est toujours pas défini
pour moi il est essentiel que dans le
périmètre
on y met là ce qu'on appelle la pointe
collège c'est à dire la partie qui est
derrière la rue hélène-boucher parce
qu'il faut absolument que le carrefour
qui les pyramides à cet endroit là soit
vraiment pris en compte avant que ça
sorte de terre parce que ce qu'on fait
là jusqu'à présent c'est qu'on construit
après on se demande ce qu'on va faire
pour la circulation
donc pour nous c'est prioritaire de
traiter ce carrefour et pour ça on pense
qu'il faut absolument que sept points
deux collèges soient incluses alors là
zagol ans quand même non oui on fait
rêver
oui évidemment tout ça déjà est
prédéfini de toute façon vers le projet
comme un vulgaire
ça paraît logique tout d'abord la
démarche qui a été choisie est une
démarche longue
c'est la démarche atouts approche du
développement du parle de développement
durable et opérations d'urbanisme que
c'est pas étonnant que ça prenne du
temps
c'est vrai qu'aussi avec l'agglo ça
prend peut-être encore plus de temps que
dans d'autres villes
on le voit paul pour le pour le plh par
exemple
donc là la question n'est pas là les
choses vont être définis maintenant
assez rapidement pendant six ans on a
payer les pénalités sru voisins pendant
six ans il nous manque 460 logements de
plus alors moi sur cette affaire là il
va falloir se décider très vite et moi
j'ai pris des positions claires je vous
invite à aller consulter mon site
internet vous aurez ma position sur
l'église voisins le bretonneux et en
particulier sur la zone de la remise
je pense que le dossier de l'église a
bloqué tout le développement de la
remise depuis six habitants il faut
arrêter et il faut trancher entre les
politiques le diocèse il faut prendre
une décision très rapidement mon ma
proposition est la suivante il faut bien
sûr sur la remise avoir des logements
des équipements publics
moi j'aurai un programme spécifique
dédié aux primo accédants
un peu comme ça a été fait primo
accident vie s'y noie un peu comme ça a
été fait à montigny et guyancourt
on n'a jamais eu ça encore à voisins moi
je veux qu'il y ait des programmes de
logements dédiés aux primo accédants
heavy sinois comme cela a été fait pour
écouter il faut il faut être sérieux
parce que là il ya des chiffres qui sont
lancés comme ça qui sont absolument pas
réel franchement c'est comme
l'endettement aussi en comme ça de
lancer qui a trois fois plus
d'endettement qu'en 2008 c'est
totalement faux il faut pour être
sérieux je veux dire c'est vrai que
pendant six ans on t'a pas vu beaucoup
donc mais il faut réactualiser quand
même cédé ces données parlons de la zac
de la remise je suis complètement et
l'intégralité de ce débat à revoir sur
notre site internet dédié aux
municipales les prochains débats à
suivre sur l'antenne de téléphiles ce
sera ce mardi à 20h coignières puis bois
d'arcy et puis jeudi à 20 heures
également manier
un mot de liste sur chacune de ces trois
communes parmi les thématiques abordées
logement urbanisme fiscalité ou encore
le dossier est de la nationale 10 et
puis quelques fois les débats n'évolue
pas forcément comme on pourrait
l'imaginer dans vos quelques jours vous
pourrez aussi suivre sur notre antenne
le rendez vous que nous avons choisi de
consacrer à la ville de trappes
l'enregistrement de ce débat a déjà eu
lieu et si le maire guy malandain avait
annoncé auparavant qu'il ne serait pas
présent son opposant ump
othman nasri devait lui et participer
voici un extrait de ce débat en plateau
également ce jour-là le représentant du
front de gauche claude miserey alors
j'ai beaucoup de respect et d'estimé
pour luc miserez et pour le parti
communiste qu'il représente mais étant
donné le ralliement programmée au second
tour un monsieur malandain je crois que
ce débat n'a pas beaucoup de sens
alors je suis conscient de de vous
mettre dans l'embarras ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas mon souhait je suis
sincèrement désolé d'avoir à le faire
mais je suis candidat à la tête d'une
liste d'union de l'opposition de
trappistes de droite et de gauche qui
sont opposés à la gestion municipale
actuelle de monsieur malandain on s'emm
absence je vais devoir profiter de ce
débat il n'y a pas de raison que les
trappistes soient lésés par rapport aux
autres villes et j'invite luc miserait
s'ils le souhaitent à quitter le plateau
avec moi parce que pour moi un débat
électoral sans le maire sortant candidat
j'assurerai mes propos entreprenons
d'une certaine manière les
téléspectateurs en otage nous annoncions
à un débat entre vous devriez le plateau
ça n'était pas prévu qu'il est mieux au
courant que moi
c'est que nos colistiers de ce qu'on va
faire
au deuxième tour c'est à dire à la
lecture des résultats du premier tour
parce que les résultats du premier tour
sont pas encore écrit donc je pense que
c'est une petite usurpation quand même
que de penser pour les autres donc moi
je me permets pas de pensée pour l'ump
donc j'aimerais que l'ump nous nous
laisse décider avant de se prononcer
pour nous moi je souhaite rester
monsieur n'à seront invités à partir on
a des choses à dire et donc si on ne
peut que regretter effectivement la non
présence de monsieur le maire mais en
termes de démocratie on en parlera
peut-être un peu plus loin parce que ça
dénote bien quand même
certains types de comportements qui pour
nous n'ont plus lieu d'être dans une
démocratie moderne municipales 2014
l'émission qui revient mardi prochain à
18h30 le tour de la campagne électorale
dans les yvelines
excellente soirée